[Music]
for a few days now we've been traveling
through key battleground states
including
ohio where you find us now it's all part
of our series
at america's crossroads every four years
the presidential hopefuls
compete for the hearts and minds of
ohioans
but they all know that they are also
competing with a second great love
and that's football five miles south of
here in the suburb
of kettering we found the crossroads of
america's passion
and america's future
from the moment we arrived at a youth
flag football game here
it was pretty clear people have been
watching the news
yeah hey how you doing but how do they
feel about talking politics
we see a lot of signs for trump we see a
lot of signs for biden
and if i was to have one it would say
presidents are temporary wu-tang is
forever
one parent lingered though and as it
turned out brandon sauk
had a lot on his mind which of the two
presidential candidates this year would
you say
we'll build a better america for these
kids
it's complicated because if you just
take
what you hear on a broad level like
i'm white my son is african-american so
which candidate best represents our
family
that's a difficult question what is your
decision going to come down to in these
next
few weeks for me i have to balance
how heavily i hold and cherish life
that's a buzzword
but my son's life matters we've all
talked about that everyone's heard that
but the life whether it be before birth
after birth
i don't think it's a clear issue are you
an undecided voter then
you could call it that really yeah i
didn't know that undecided voters really
existed at this late stage in the
election
yeah the shock of meeting an actual
undecided voter was soon followed by a
sting
it looks that's me saying
hello to a local ohio honey worker
starting to swell up a little bit
after some minor first aid we made our
way over to watch the browns face off
against the cowboys
nice catch kaden tabitha honaker west is
almost as passionate in her support of
president trump
as she is for her son cayden and
politically that's a change from 2016.
i was taking more of a democratic stance
because i was in poverty
wow and let's go browns
oh interception yeah that's trouble
there we go
and i listened to my father and i voted
for trump
and i was proud that i did and i think
he's done us good
you know he said some stupid things but
that's trump
which helps explain why some people here
told us they aren't thrilled with either
of their options
to me it's it's not going to matter when
we're the other you sound exhausted by
politics
i am i'm very exhausted so i think that
it's just a person that's representing
the country i don't think that
anything's going to change but on that
point folks on the other side of the
field
differed the pandemic is
taking over our lives and it didn't have
to be this way
you don't like the division yeah i don't
like the division and
i don't like what it's done to people i
mean people are
cutting other people out of their lives
because of politics so
it sounds like what you're both saying
is to put the country on a better path
you like joe biden yes you're hesitant
to well you know i just i know this is
going to be on tv and i don't
i don't necessarily want people to
because you know i'm friends
i'm friends with people on both sides
and i don't ever want that to be an
issue
with people i wish it was a better
situation but you know i think that
that we definitely need change that's
all i can say really
[Applause]
so that last voter guys i mean she
really illustrates something that's
going on here in the country
and that is our division is really as
passionate and extreme as parents on
different sides
of the field in a youth sports uh
match-up and i'll give you an example uh
based on the polling i mean
right now at this particular moment the
republican approval rating
for donald trump and the democratic
approval rating for donald trump
the gap between the two is wider than it
has ever been in the history of modern
polling
that is how divided we are at this
particular moment in america yeah i get
her reluctance to say anything
tony because you're attacked no matter
what you do but i do like kayden's mom
we know where she stands about her
presidential vote and her son
you go katie i like carol all right tony
thank you very much